pretend you're a trash talking version
of Magnus Carlson how do you beat Hikaru
well well well if it isn't he Hikaru
Nakamura prepare yourself for a lesson
in humiliation my friend hear us how I
the mighty Magnus Carlson who trounce
you exploit your predictable opening
sakaru your opening repertoire is as
predictable as your online rants ID use
that against you and prepare a devious
strap leaving you squirming right from
the start turn your aggression against
you oh kitaru we all know you love your
aggressive blade but guess what ill
Channel your aggression and turn it back
on you I ll calmly defend and let you
overextend then strike with surgical
Precision drown you in positional
Brilliance Hikaru you may have speed but
I have finesse ill art maneuver you in
the middle game suffocate your pieces
and leave you drowning in a sea of
positional superiority crush your
Tactical dreams your Tactical skills are
impressive Ill give you that but I my
Agnes Carlson and the master of
calculation I ll navigate the Tactical
Minefield with ease leaving you with
nothing but Shattered Dreams exploit
your time trouble we all know you
struggle with time management Hikaru I
ll exploit your weakness by keeping the
position complex and forcing you into
time trouble watch as the clock ticks
away your chances Play Mind Games Hikaru
you Renown for your emotional outbursts
Ill get under your skin poke and prod
until your frustration reaches its
boiling point your anger will Cloud your
judgment and victory will be mine till
the deal with end game Mastery finally
when all hope is lost ill take you into
the end game my endgame skills are
unparalleled and Ill showcase the beauty
of precision as I smoothly convert my
advantage into a decisive Victory so
kikaru Nakamura prepare to be humbled to
witness the Brilliance of Magnus Carlson
in action your defeat is inevitable and
Ill Rebel in every moment of it brace
yourself for the master is here to teach
you a lesson you want to soon forgets
don't I'm playing Hikaru okay
oh what did chat CPT tell me to do
uh play the London have self-confidence
okay let's play Knight C3
oh
right before the tournament I asked
chassashypt how to prepare for Hikaru
this is like Wesley so it's about to buy
or Tabata by Wesley so
I think I have to take
I don't remember my theory
I didn't get to this part in Daniel's
jobava London course
um takes
I'll just take
Knight F3
because the queen ties down the bishop
it's a good move though
if I Castle
most take on D5
I need self-confidence
that's Castle
be brave
I'm not sure if this is like Brave or or
dumb but I guess we'll find out
I'm a bit more developed but he has a
bishop here he wants to Fork me
if I play
if I play rookie one
there there
is king of seven yeah
might be five
it's so annoying that E5 is coming
more developed
I'm not sure if it matters
Bishop G3 is a safe move
and now maybe Knight B5 no that hangs
material
uh if I
have to play like Rook rookie three but
then E5
and take take
I have an idea
so I'm walking into the tactics
he doesn't go for them
Knight B5
I really want to suck and like somehow
win something
[Music]
maybe that would just lose something
I'm already below a minute
and he has a bishop pair
Rook here
at least I'm getting some lifting in
a risky move
things are left hanging I think he's
going to take taken with my Pawn
but then I have Rook D4 Maybe
E5 D5 could be weak
I mean there's Bishop A5 Knight D4
I play B4
I'll just be safe
it's so easy to blunder here
I want to play F4
he sees my plans
so I hung upon
but it's not so simple
I have some Knight G5 or Knight
E4
Bishop 5x4
I think these Pawns
they take King G6
where's my tricky trick
let's see my trick
yeah
good move
no
okay I resign
uh
I went both my horses yeah it looked
really tricky but he handled it well
prepared to be humbled
wait I'm the one who's humbled